大家好,在这里我给大家介绍一下下岸油的分销商，它怎样从上岸的分销商那里复制商品,在这个第一次进入这个软件页面的时候,如果你还没有选择使用模式,那么这个下游分销商能需要选择分销商模式。选择好之后,可以看到左边的这些菜单都已经经过刷新,这些全部都是分销商模式下的这个菜单。
那在这里的话,你可以看到一个复制商品。
复制商品这里,你可以点击管理复制规则,首先你需要添加一个复制规则。
这个规则起个名字,然后状态起用,然后这里复制,比如说手机描述不需要,然后这里上架。
等等这些都可以选,这里有个开启实时同步。
如果您勾选了,比你勾选了几个要实时同步的数据,那么在复制之后,这两个商品之间就会开启实时同步。
当上游的分销商这个商品,它的库存价格发生变动的时候,会实时同步更新到您的所新复制的这个商品。
我们先把它关掉,然后点确定。
可以看到这个规则已经创建好了。在这里您可以随时关,进一用,或者说查看这个规则,编辑都是可以,或者删除。
接下来我们来到这个表签,选择商品复制。
在这个页面,您可以看到这里显示的是上级分销商。
如果您有好几个商品分销商,您可以选择一个。
这是这个上级分销商的授权,这里显示的都是这个分销商给您授权的商品。
您可以从这些商品里面选择进行复制。
我们来选一个。
这里也可以选择定时复制。
我们可以选择一个复制的时间。
我们现在一起复制就可以。
比如说复制规则,选择刚才填的规则。
然后勾选几个店铺分类,这些可以多选。
然后运费模板,您可以用原商品的运费模板,直接复制一模一样的过来。
您也可以用自己的某一个运费模板,然后点确定。
好了,这下就提交了一个复制任务。
来到这边,您可以看一下,这个复制任务正在处理。
里面有一个商品,我们来查询一下,再看看。
现在还是正在处理中,稍等一下。
其实您不需要在这里倒。
这个完全是离线复制的。
您可以把这个浏览器关掉。
它都不会停止,都会在后台默默地复制。
您再一次再登了过来的时候,您看到它可能就已经复制好了。
好了,现在看到这个已经完成了,已经成功了一个。
点这个任务ID,可以直接跳转到搜索这个ID下。
可以看到这个商品,它已经复制好了。
好了,在这个页面上,大家可以看到这条复制的记录。
目标商品的ID,就是新复制生产的这个商品ID。
用它的图片数、它的状态或者时间,在这里还可以导出这个复制记录。
如果有发生复制失败的情况,您可以勾选失败,然后查询,查询出来这些失败的记录,
然后您可以点重新复制,点这个重新复制按钮就可以了。
好了,在这里就给大家讲了怎样从上级分销商去复制商品。
好的,谢谢。